So we've been talking about
security planning and management.
There are many sort of different
pieces that make up this whole process
of planning and
then managing the security.
How do we bring it all together?
If you're going to go explain
this to someone in a few minutes.
What are the things you
should be talking about.
Well first of all you're
going to say that
there are things that are of
value which are at risk.
Maybe your reputation,
maybe your intellectual property,
there are assets that are of
value which are at risk.
So then you're going to talk about the
risk comes from certain threats sources.
Not only there are bad guys out there.
Of course, we have certain
vulnerabilities, those are the attack
vectors, that's why those threat
sources would be able to do us harm.
That's why we need to worry about,
the risk comes from the fact, not just
because we have something of value, but
that thing could be harmed or
could be breached.
So the threats and attack vectors,
really talking about threats and
vulnerabilities.
Together they come together,
result in an attack.
So an attack then leads to a breach.
And that's where we have
the adverse consequences.
So if we have that, we have to talk
about things that are of value.
We have to talk about threats.
These two are the reasons that help us
explain that there is something at risk.
And the amount or
level of risk that we may have.
And the way to manage that
risk is to plan for security,
implement whatever controls that
are meaningful, and then sort of manage
that in terms of controls, people,
processes and things like that.
And all that has to be done, again,
this control that we're talking about,
of course we're going to
look at the cost.
The benefits they offer?
What impact they have?
How user friendly they are?
Things like that.
So we have to sort of look into
the controls that we have,
what their effectiveness is.
Then we have to identify people.
It's their job to worry about security.
We have to empower them to do it.
They have to have the budget,
they have to be able to have
policies that can be enforced and
things like that.
And people have to be held
responsible and accountable.
Because we know that
something was wrong.
They should be called to
answer what exactly happened.
And no matter how well you do that, we
have to plan for something going wrong.
And when something goes wrong,
a response is going to be needed.
Remediation has to happen.
There shouldn't be any surprises.
We should be prepared and
have a plan in place saying if something
bad were to happen, this is how
we're going to respond to it.
Of course, people as we said, need to
be aware of the importance of security.
The guiding principals, the do's and
don'ts, all the things we
were talking about under security
policy so we need to think about that.
And finally we need to understand and
people have to recognize
that a proactive option is what gets
you ahead of the threats in some sense.
Threats change continuously.
If you're just going to be in reactive
mode something new is going to come and
hit you and you're going to suffer the
same sort of thing that you did before.
So proactively addressing the risk and
the threats and the vulnerabilities and
having a champion to do that is another
part of this security planning and
management that we're talking about.
Overall understand what is of value,
why there's risk to it
which is the threats and
the vulnerabilities we're talking about.
And then plan, implement, manage,
and do that all proactively.
That's sort of bringing it all together
when it comes to security planning and
management